i have to ask you about
what
was the catalyst because you do have a
child and that was the catalyst like
really it was it was like
how do i live with myself knowing that i
am the example for this young person
if i can't speak up for myself and for
other people especially in a time
that such as this that we are living in
when these things are getting pushed to
the surface and now is the time for
truth and healing and having those hard
conversations and if i run away from
this now
how do what do i what do i tell my child
you know be that person if you have the
platform and the privilege to help other
people dear god use it
and um and that i just felt i i just had
to do it um and i feel there should be
exceptions to the statute of limitations
because we're all sitting here going how
do these people get away with for so
long how are there so many victims why
can't anything be done and it's because
they've run out of time
and um
you know
i i i am
for the past couple weeks been you know
running around talking about this
promoting the documentary but
last night i did get home
and
break uh because i've been running
around having to be so strong and clear
and concise and you know you're sitting
there you've got all this pressure
you're the spokesperson for not you know
not just this documentary but for all
domestic violence survivors and you're
going oh god did i say it right did i
word it right what am i going to get
sued for like how is this going to come
back to
to hurt me and then i stopped and
thought i should not be this scared to
tell the truth
and and so the system is working but not
the right system
and and and we've got to find a balance
to to leave room for for reform
but also give survivors this cushion
that they need especially when we know
so much more about trauma now and how
long it takes to process do you want to
take the phoenix act beyond california
absolutely um and i feel like this will
be a part of my life you know forever
and and some people don't understand
that they think god don't you want to
move on do anyone just stop and just
like never think about this again but
it's like you know by healing others you
also heal yourself and and it gives the
pain a purpose
and if i can turn this into a healing
moment and a moment for education and
prevention and to shine some light on
this issue that is severely under
reported and understood then that brings
me happiness you know that that brings
me healing as well i think that your
documentary is such a game changer um
for
the reasons of helping people realize
that trauma does take a long time to
realize
for going out there and fighting and
changing the legal system
i mean i just have to say that i think
what i've learned about you
is
that you might be one of the best
mothers i've ever seen in my life
how you take everything that you've
learned from your parents
how you've managed to heal with them
continue to work with them
see
human beings for who they are i have so
much admiration for you
you are the living example of how a
human being can function in this world
process protect others tell their truth
you are my new hero oh my god i'm so
honored that you would share in this
experience for everybody and you will
change the world and you will save lives
from it you really will that's the goal
that's the goal
that is the goal
there is no
[Applause]
there's there's
often a misconception you know with with
survivors of abuse that we are angry and
just always out for revenge and it's
it's no like i really really want to
approach us from a place of healing
and and really that is what we want we
want healing and and accountability and
and that's that's what we're asking for
and safety you know like i think there's
so much time
and you do there's a levity to it
thank you evan rachel wood for more
information about the statue of
limitations for domestic violence in
your state please go to
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
and you can watch the two-part hbo
documentary film phoenix rising which is
now on hbo and hbo max you are an
incredible i'm so honored to do this
with you thank you
[Music]